The Big Lebowski is a 1998 comedy
written and directed by the Coen
brothers but there are more layers to
peel back and much of their work is
meant to be greater commentary on other
things beyond bowling and bad porno
movies The Big Lebowski is also a film
about both literal and figurative
castration when one says figurative
castration it means the idea of a man
feeling as if he is losing the qualities
that he believes makes him a man Walter
sees himself as manly toting around
firearms and talking about war service
but he is still a complete servant to
his ex-wife it is the big lebowski a
masterpiece after premiering in 1998
this coin brothers comedy has gone from
underground art house film to cult
classic status growing a big following
over the years particularly with college
students The Big Lebowski has sparked
memes books
hell even conventions based on the
bizarre circumstances surrounding
Jeffrey Lebowski
dude this hasn't shocked me that much as
I found the film entertaining from day
one it was always kind of that weird but
cool flick it introduced two new friends
for a surreal laugh but since it's grown
in popularity people have been reading a
lot more into it there's literature
analyzing his philosophies and meanings
I had a professor whose lineup of films
along with Citizen Kane and Apocalypse
Now was Big Lebowski and yes even some
of our video series like renegade cut
put their own unique interpretation
about what the film means which of
course begs the question doesn't mean
anything and is it even worth spending
the time to figure out if it means
anything the story about a lazy
unemployed bowler who gets mixed up in a
kidnapping plot sounds like it has a lot
going on he has a psychotic Vietnam vet
for a friend a crazy competitor named
Jesus an artist who has randomly
selected him to be the sperm daddy of
her child her father who's a millionaire
with the same name who wants him to go
after his kidnapped wife whose half his
age the German nihilus who kidnapped her
the head of a pornographic industry
a whole bunch of crazy ass characters
and what does this all add up to pretty
much nothing yeah most people either
have like a lesson a moral a story arc
is something that the character goes
through to show some kind of change but
here stuff just kind of happens and then
it just kind of stops but to the film's
credit that's where a lot of the surreal
comedy comes in well don't get me wrong
there's other fine things in the movie
like the dream sequences the blow ups
conversations that seem more focused on
wasting time rather than furthering
anything but what makes this movie stand
out from other movies is that you're
waiting to see what it's all adding up
to and it's never really revealed we've
seen other films have been declared a
giant waste of time but why is it
everyone says this one is so good what
did this film do different that those
other films couldn't well to help figure
out that distinction I decide to compare
it to another Coen Brothers film that
pretty much seems to be about nothing
burne after reading this film is very
similar in that it has a lot of big
events and a lot of big characters but
ultimately adds up to very little so why
is Big Lebowski remembered and
celebrated more than this well for one
everything builds on top of each other
and are connected and burn after reading
even if it's building up to the
punchline that nobody learns anything
because there's probably nothing to
learn what do we learn Palmer I guess we
learned not to do it again yes sir I'm
fucked if I know what we did but in Big
Lebowski so many things could have been
cut from the movie and it wouldn't have
affected anything important to the
structure the fantasies could have been
cut that talk with the cop could have
been cut Donnie's death could have been
cut half the conversations good Ward the
first one among the friends could be
told in two lines I think that guy with
the same name as you should replace your
rug you're right and that's it this
scene could have been over in a couple
seconds but look how long it takes them
to get around to that this was a value
dogs had to run together dude my rug
were you listening - dude story Donnie
laughter were you listening to the dudes
story I was bowling so you have
frame of reference here Donnie like a
child wanders in in the middle of a
movie and what about Walter what's the
point of you there's no reason here's my
point dude there's no fucking reason why
this ya won't so what's your point oh
it's not even a matter of ending the
conversation as friggin starting the
conversation even the narrator doesn't
seem to really know what he's talking
about at the very beginning sometimes
there's a man don't say hero cuz what's
a hero but sometimes there's a man and
I'm talking about the dude here but
sometimes there's a man sometimes
there's a man ah watch my train of
thought here that's setting the film's
tone and even he kind of doesn't give a
shit hell I'm gonna introduce Tim enough
another big difference is that in burn
after reading while it is a complicated
plot we do see or at least hear what
happens to every story that is begun
they all have some sort of conclusion
with Big Lebowski a lot of these have no
resolution whatever happened to the kid
who stole the car why'd he steal the car
to begin with does the dude ever get his
rug back what happens with Maude and
trying to get pregnant did bunny ever
pay back jackie treehorn and if not
where does that go are they ever gonna
do another bowling tournament that was
built up so much but then randomly
dropped by Walter's religious day of
rest
jabbers Chaves the list goes on so in a
way Big Lebowski is more unique because
unlike Burn After Reading where the
payoff is building up to nothing this
one doesn't even fully have the build up
half the situation's just stopped before
they can even start to really get going
in most other narratives this would be
seen as very sloppy storytelling and
there's definitely critics out there
that say it is here too I just thought
they were so obviously written
particularly Jeff Bridges character as
this dude type but for others what makes
these strange situations that just sort
of start and stop at random so
interesting is the reactions from the
dude I remember actually starting to
laugh as the film was wrapping up I said
to myself is that really it you're not
going to resolve any of these other
stories that you started you're just
going to end with the
dude abides well the dude abides but
then when I looked at the whole thing
that did seem to make the most sense it
doesn't matter to us what happens in all
these other situations because it
doesn't matter to him to a lot of people
in a strange way the dude is sort of the
perfect balance of living a happy life I
know that sounds strange but like I said
there's books written about this but
really think about it
he doesn't ignore everything that's
going on around him he gets angry he
gets involved he fights back in hell he
doesn't want to see someone die because
of him they're gonna kill that for a
woman man the fuck are you talking about
but at the same time his goal seems to
be just live comfortably with his own
needs even if those needs are just of a
lazy jobless bum he clearly doesn't care
what people think of him I mean I don't
know how many people would have a
picture of Nixon bowling or proclaim how
much they hate the Eagles I had a rough
night and I hate the fucking Eagles man
yeah I throw that at all your cat
fucking you later but he does still have
a moral Center at least enough to care
when someone he knows is gonna get hurt
he's found what he's wanted to do
discovered a way to make it work
embraced it and fed off the rewards that
wouldn't satisfy most people his age but
seems to satisfy him he's clearly
offered nothing to the world and has
shown no responsibility to it but he's
also matched a way to keep happy without
ever hurting anyone truth be told
there's probably why so many college
students enjoy this film not only
because it's funny but because it
celebrates tranquility in simplicity as
well as a shit ton of laziness the dude
is a terrible role model in terms of
forming your goals and finding out how
to achieve them but I think you could
argue he is a good role model and
showing how to appreciate the goals you
have accomplished even if they are few
with a world building us up for great
progress and great things that we want
to achieve very few people ever actually
achieve what they were aiming for it's
not
down there who's the fucker now mr.
Reiner you punch a fucking cry-baby so
here's a character that obviously set
his goals and standards pretty low he is
pathetic he is a loser but at least he's
content with that and that seems to be
the glue that keeps the movie afloat
like I said before you can take out so
many of the strange elements in the
story I wouldn't really affect much but
what you can take out is the dude
himself his reactions is what holds it
together how he accepts challenges or
doesn't even acknowledge the problems
that are put before it I guess in an odd
way that does kind of make this film a
masterpiece because no other film has
accomplished this in such a bizarre way
and with such a strong long-term
acceptance of it I can't think of any
other movies really like this that
follow such a strange bizarre structure
but still kind of works while others
will no doubt bring their own
interesting interpretations on the
film's meaning and relevance the one
thing you can't deny through any of
those interpretations is that he is
gonna be what makes this movie last for
years and still have people talking
about in the future so yeah despite his
more than obvious faults he has still
found something that can be strangely
admired and in his own unique way he's
discovered how to strive for very little
achieve very little yet be content with
very little he did it because he wanted
to and not because anybody else told him
to he'll who the hell would he's selfish
and disgusting but he's still happy with
who he is and bugging no one in the
process and that's something to
appreciate and also talked about and if
bad things from the world come in to
challenge his way of life he does what
any strange it wise happy person would
do he abides what about you not take
comfort in that I'm the Nostalgia Critic
and I don't know which Lebowski quote to
end with Donna you're out of your
element sure ah
that morning white Russians always the
best
you